sleep disorders are a mix of problems
insomnia is actually due to mineral
deficiencies you take all 90 essential
nutrients 60 minerals you take 60
minerals 16 vitamins 12 century no acids
essential fatty acids and sleep comes
easy can take a balance of our liquid
ask you FX plus before bedtime and
ensure a good night's sleep sleep apnea
is a normal procedure look at a newborn
baby they have sleep apnea you look at a
dog sleep you look at an elephant sleep
you look at the giraffe sleep every
vertebrae has sleep apnea it's an
absolutely normal behavior medical
system for financial purposes has turned
this into a Z's with CPAP machines and
surgeries absolutely criminal there is
no such thing as people dying in sleep
apnea or snoring the only time you're
going to die from snoring and sleep
apnea is when your sleep partner xuxa